una noticia que conmociona en un año
2020 que ya nos ha llenado de dolor y
conmoción para argentina por supuesto
habrá quienes en su vida no le ha
prestado demasiada atención a maradona a
maradona o quienes consideran que es una
figura polémica pero en general en
argentina es una figura que despierta
mucho cariño respeto y admiración sobre
todo así que el impacto ha sido muy
fuerte y para medirlo no más que ver que
el presidente de la nación alberto
fernández
alberto fernández hace unos minutos nada
más anunció tres días de duelo por la
muerte de diego armando maradona está lo
que también funciona como una
confirmación de la información decías al
inicio que por lo pronto se sabía por
medios argentinos así empezó en un
momento primero con rumores y luego con
información en medios con confirmaciones
parciales y finalmente la noticia se fue
confirmando y si se cree la confirmación
definitiva la da esta declaración de
tres días de duelo por parte del
presidente alberto fernández